[Music]
in our morning rounds how diet soft
drinks might have consequences for your
brain new research finds having at least
one artificially sweetened drink a day
could double the risk of developing a
stroke or dementia a 2015 study showed
that Americans drink more than 3 billion
gallons of diet soda a year our doctor
Taryn Rula is a cardiologist at Norwell
health good morning good morning Nora
all right what would account for a link
between diet soda and dementia this is a
beverage class that's on the rise
particularly in children and it's
marketed to many as a healthier
alternative but is it this is not the
first study to point out a link with
diet sodas and vascular events in
particular stroke it is the first to
kind of highlight the risk of dementia
and so the question really is is it the
drink or is it not the drink and so they
tried to kind of look at other factors
that might be playing in physical
inactivity smoking your diet quality and
they really still found that association
when they when they accounted for those
factors however and this is important
when they accounted for things like
diabetes and vascular risk factors and
high blood pressure they no longer
really saw that significant association
between the diet drink and dementia and
Stroke which tells us that probably
these effects are being mediated through
diabetes hypertension and vascular
things so is it the drink itself that
somehow leading people to gain weight
and develop diabetes and causing it or
is it a higher risk population people
are already diabetic and overweight who
are saying I want to get healthier I'm
switching and it was their previous high
risks that caused this the American
Beverage Association responded to the
studies saying quote low-calorie
sweeteners have been proven safe and
there is nothing in this research that
counters this well-established fact
so how definitive can we say this
research is then this is an
observational study it does not prove
cause and effect there are biological
hypotheses that say maybe these types of
drinks are increasing your cravings for
high glycemic high caloric foods leaving
to waken and diabetes maybe they're
affecting hormones they're affecting
your microbiome they are somehow have a
component in them that is
pro-inflammatory the bottom line is we
really don't know we need more research
this increases our awareness about that
so do you think that people because we
use it to lose weight or to reduce the
sugar does this mean go back to the
sugar ecole is that it does
we know that added sugar is bad for your
cardiovascular health it raises your
risk of diabetes hypertriglyceridemia so
you really want to stick to the
recommendation less than nine teaspoons
a day of sugar added for men less than
six teaspoons a day for women and really
water is the safest thing and in fact
there was a study by these authors the
same week that said that when they
looked at sugary beverages and they
studied people's brains they had
decreased memory they had decreased
brain volume so do not just make the
decision to switch back well I know from
the liable sources you drink a lot of
diet drinks i hate's mean you're
changing I had to think about it
yesterday when I reached to get in my
diet soda know what kind of diet soda do
you drink I ever eat every day I drink
right oh yeah I got to think about it
now I may change what's in my cup
alright Tara thanks